Patrick on the Kickstarter page 4 in
pursuit of silence you have a quote from
a French German artist is it Hans jean
arp that's right yeah yeah yeah and the
quote is beautiful it's a very long
quote yeah what what where did you look
for this or how did you confidence i
think when i was putting together the
business plan for in pursuit of silence
that were passing around to investors i
knew that i wanted to kind of sort of
set the stage for investors with a quote
and so I just scoured the web to find
that and then I you know you always have
to research who's actually saying it to
make sure it's a credible person and not
a serial killer or something you know
and so jean arp turns out to be this
incredible artist you know use one of
the the founding members of the data
artists movement back into that early
1900s and it was just like it was so
good and so perfect as far as how i
wanted to kind of sum up and set the
stage for this documentary yeah have you
thought of who your audience will be for
the phone I thought about who the
audience will be for the film yeah I've
definitely given some thought to the
audience you know every anybody living
in a major city I think will be
intrigued by this topic people who live
amidst noise every day of their lives
will be interested in this phone aside
from that there's these niche markets of
course there's a lot of noise activists
in the world and noise organizations and
people who deal in sound design in
acoustic design so all those sort of
pockets of people were hoping to tap
into and share the film with and have
you done this in the past or you've
written an outline of how we'll go I
mean I don't miss the film itself right
right do you have a specific plan that's
a good question um this I'm still
developing the idea that but as I
develop it y am sort of putting this
mental outline together at some point I
do plan on on mapping out the entire
film as much as possible I wasn't able
to do that with the last film les sous
because it was just kind of wasn't
narrative about one guy we're following
his story and there's no outline
whatsoever that we can even put together
but with this kind of film I feel like
yeah I can sort of I can figure out what
the direction will be as far as the
content like how I want the narrative to
kind of unfold and how I want the
conversation to unfold so yeah there's
definitely some more prep that I can do
on this film yeah i'm using a lot of
interviews with people or will it just
be studies and your beautiful seminar be
yeah the the film will be comprised of
what we typically see in documentaries
in part you'll see some interviews with
people and you'll follow that will
follow the narrative of some individuals
possibly a deaf person probably a monk
people like that and then we'll intercut
that with experts speaking about certain
studies that have been conducted over
the years but what I'm most excited
about the film is I'm trying to mix in
kind of the experimental tradition of
filmmaking into this film a little bit
it's going to be kind of a hybrid
documentary experimental film where I
really want this film to be very much of
something rather than about something I
don't want people leaving the theater
just hearing about noise and silence and
hearing people talk about but I want
them to really experience what that
feels like I want to juxtapose noisy
segments and scenes with silent scenes
and I want them to know what it feels
like to experience silence and I want it
to be sort of a restorative kind of
experience for people to at the end of
the watching this film I want them to to
kind of like have a sense of relief
almost in this desire to seek out more
silence in their lives
you